- [Narrator] This is the US-made Abrams,
one of the three types
of Western style tanks
that Ukraine is expecting
from its allies.
And this is the T-72,
the Soviet era tank that's
been used most frequently
in the war so far.
As The Wall Street Journal first reported,
the US Senate's allies
have agreed to send tanks
to Ukraine ahead of more
intense fighting in the spring.
Abrams and German-made
Leopards are being sent
to Kyiv in addition to
UK made Challenger 2s.
So as Ukraine says getting
a significant number
of those weapons would be a game changer,
here's how heavy vehicles
from the West match up
to Russia's older, but
much larger tank fleet.
(weapon firing)
First, let's look at why Ukraine argues
that tanks are so important.
- So the front lines
of this war have been pretty
static in the last few months.
A lot of the fighting
has been taking place
along these vast plains
and on small hills,
and that's the kind of terrain
and landscape that allows
the big military vehicles
to operate pretty efficiently.
- [Narrator] The two main types
of armored vehicles being used
in Ukraine right now are main battle tanks
and infantry fighting
vehicles, also known as IFVs,
tanks of heavy armor, big
guns and caterpillar treads.
When tanks face each
other on the battlefield,
military experts say they typically look
for a weak point along
the front line to try
and break through and
destroy other heavy vehicles.
IFVs, on the other hand,
are smaller and lighter.
They have some of the
characteristics of tanks
but their main purpose is
transporting infantry safely
around the battlefield while
also providing fire support
with their smaller weapons.
Prior to the invasion,
Ukraine had significantly
fewer armored fighting
vehicles than Russia.
- But now Kyiv's NATO allies
are sending more modern
military vehicles to Ukraine.
- Today I'm announcing
that the United States will
be sending 31 Abram tanks
to Ukraine, the equivalent
of one Ukrainian battalion.
- [Narrator] So how will Western Tanks
help Ukrainian forces?
- Well, for tanks,
the most important
factor is survivability.
- [Narrator] Weapons experts
measure this by estimating
how resistant the vehicles
are to anti-tank weapons,
like the US-made Javelin
or the Russian Kornet,
as well as armor-piecing
rounds fired by other tanks.
Analysts say the Challenger
2 and Abrams tanks,
which were both used in the Iraq war,
are some of the most
protected tanks in the world.
That's because they both
have a composite armor
called Chobham.
It uses a combination of steel, ceramics
and other materials to create
particularly resistant plates.
Military analysts say
this protection gives them
a major advantage over the T-72,
over 500 of which have
been destroyed so far
in the Ukraine war.
German-made Leopard tanks
don't use that same armor technology
but have other similar characteristics
to the Abrams and Challenger 2,
all three types of
advanced computer systems
and modern 120 millimeter guns.
Military analysts say
they're less vulnerable
than the gun on the T-72,
which hold this ammunition
at the bottom of the turret.
On the ground, the tanks,
which are expensive,
and fewer number will also
get some extra support.
- Other armored vehicles
are just as important
and the US has also promised
to deliver 50 M2 Bradley
fighting vehicles to Ukraine.
- The Bradley has a number
of modern advantages,
including thermal imaging
quicker reload times, and
an armor that's believed
to be more resistant than
the Russian equivalents.
That includes the Soviet era BMP-2,
which have been commonly
used in the war so far.
Hundreds of these vehicles
have been destroyed
in Ukraine according to the
military tracking site Oryx,
while the US says only
three Bradleys were lost
in the Iraq war.
(soldiers speaking in foreign language)
But once Ukraine's forces get new tanks,
using them effectively won't be easy.
Many of these systems
use different ammunition
and require their own
maintenance schedules.
- It's still going to take a few months
to set up the supply
chains, the fuel lines
and the trained crews needed
for the Ukraine to take
advantage of these weapons.
And the few amounts that
have been promised so far
make it unlikely
that it's going to impact
the war anytime soon.
- [Narrator] Battlefield conditions
could also reduce their effectiveness.
The Western systems are heavier,
meaning that they can be more limited
when in boggy areas and crossing bridges.
Although its fleet is
aging and diminished,
Moscow has hundreds more
tanks in storage centers.
Ukraine, on the other hand,
says it needs 300 tanks
to push back Russian forces, many more
than the initial shipments
expected from the West.